The boy has always supported
Latino communities of color and last year we
announced an effort we
called the Quality Johnny
Program pressure and we announced a 570 million
dollar investment and that investment
went to support, on the one hand, obtaining the
management representation of people
Latinas and of color also support the
purchase of supplies from
businesses that are owned by Hispanics and of
color and on the other hand
we are also giving scholarships to
support the community and as part of this
program yesterday I am very pleased that we
announced a program that  we call it
together we grow and this program is an
investment of 50 million dollars in
the next five years and has three
pillars the first pillar is called impact
which is a business accelerator in
which through the pepsico foundation
we are giving scholarships of ten  thousand dollars
to those small businesses of
restaurants, wineries, butcher shops and this
year we are going to give to 150 businesses in 13
cities within the e  euu that is the first
pillar the second pillar we call it
digital support and help to deliver at
home and free famous delivery
and what we saw is that
Hispanic businesses do not necessarily have all
the capabilities or
understanding to be able to go to the world
digital and as a result of kobe,
basically making light reduces your market
if you are not in this digital market
then we give consultancy
and help you with all the tools
to be able to get on the network and be able to
expand your market and sell much
more we realized that around  From him, as
a result of Kobe, Hispanic businesses
had suffered disproportionately
against, let's say, white-owned businesses,
and that's why we came in to
help, and the third pillar is basically to
give them a series of essential security kits, to
support them in promoting their
products for  new to be able to have
everything they need and enough to be
able to function as a business and be very
successful  We have a website called
el chico juntos crecemos dotcom I
repeat it is called success together we grow
dotcom and there you will be able to find the
details of the program and how you
as a small merchant can
make the application and the application is
quite simple there are a few
requirements that  Obviously, we need
to do
some work to make the
application, but it is an ID, it
must have a security
number solution or a taxi identification name, and it
is made for businesses with a maximum
annual income of one million dollars and
that we can give them.  helping not
only the money is also all the
advice and knowledge that the boy has.
I tell you as a representative in
the western United States I have seen how
these tools really help
our restaurants to grow their
sales to be much more successful and not
they can but you have nothing to lose
we are a very small one of those
you see that we make a sauce  for pasta
that is unique in the usa it is a recipe from
our family we are from spain and
we have been in las vegas for 11 years and
well we decided my husband is a chef and we
recovered an old recipe
for pasta sauce that does not exist in the usa and is
unique we started  our company in
2018 we are very recent
and good six months after the launch
of our state unique and natural whole
foods and exhibit central mark the
big chains of special books of
these new received the product
because it is really unique and good from
2003 it was incredible but  He reached 2020
and clipped our wings. He tells me about the
program, he is vice president of high school, they don't
tell me that there is a toxic program that they
are doing great for small
Hispanic companies with difficulties during the
pandemic, it
was very easy between their platform, five
points, we grow dotcom.  apply super
easy super fast right away and a
response email that someone
accepts the application and well after a
few weeks  We received an email for
the very good news that for us it
has been salvation because really
with this great test of 10 thousand dollars
we can continue with our
marketing program look for the big
companies as a proxy with it really
for us it is incredible I had heard
talk about these things but you never think
they really reach the
people who tried no it's a bit
like a lottery don't divide well they
will give it but not to me but yes because for
them maybe for persico it's a
small granite  But for us it is a
great universe, so I encourage
all manufacturers, producers, and all
small Hispanic companies
to get information
together, but we should see if
together we grow dotcom, there are a lot
of resources, they are also helping me
with the  issue of seeking
financing because we are going to launch
new products and as soon as the
pandemic passes we have expanded our range and we
need a bit of  Ito of financing
they are helping me in the whole issue of
financing how to get it and
really many resources
my husband and I are very grateful and that at
a given moment because it is considered three
I can no longer go ahead with the
pandemic has clipped our wings
completely but this is not going to help us
to take off again and advance our
new products and well, encourage
everyone that you can see our
houses that are delicious and very healthy
100% natural